نجح الاتحاد الاوروبي المكون من 27 دوله
بالحصول على
42.5% من طاقته من مصادر متجدده مثل طاقه
الرياح والطاقه الشمسيه بحلول عشرين
ثلاثين طموحات اوروبيه في اتباع نهج خالي
من الانبعاثات الكربونيه قد لا تتم وفق
خططهم فالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه غيرت
المسار بعض الدول الاوروبيه عادت مجددا
للاعتماد على الفحم والوقود الاحفوري كما
حصل في المانيا مع ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
رغبه الكتله في تخفيض الانبعاثات تقابلها
تحديات اخرى على ارض الواقع
بحسب تقرير جرين بيس ارتفعت الانبعاثات من
الطائرات الخاصه في اوروبا بشكل كبير ما
مجموعها 5.3 مليون طن من ثاني اكسيد
الكربون في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه وهذه
الكميه من ثاني اكسيد الكربون اكثر مما
تنتجه اوغندا بعدد سكاني نحو 46 مليون
نسمه في عام الباحثون وجدوا ان عدد رحلات
الطائرات الخاصه في اوروبا زاد بنسبه 64%
العام الماضي مع زياده بعثات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون باكثر من الضعف معظمها في فرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا كما ان للطائرات
الخاصه بعثات اعلى بكثير من وسائل النقل
الاخرى فرحله متوسطه في عام واحد تنتج
ثاني اكسيد الكربون ما يعادل قياده
السياره من باريس الى روما 16 مره وفق
التقرير
بدورها وجهت منظمه اوكسفام اصابع الاتهام
الى اصحاب الطائرات الخاصه عن مسؤولياتهم
عن انبعاثات غازات الدفيئه اكثر بمليون
مره من الشخص العادي رش خياط العرضيه